foreign
ERS will be facing one of the top
defenses in the National Football League
Sunday when the Broncos roll into Las
Vegas now that Raider offense will be on
point Sunday because they're going to
have to be Denver is third in Total
Defense second in points allowed third
and passing defense and first in red
zone defense so car and Company will
have to be on target now the key stat
will be staying ahead on down a distance
in other words they need big plays on
first down
there's a lot of good football players
on this team that and we're sitting here
and we're like man we're owing three
right now you know and and we've all
been through adversity we've all been
through through things in our life or in
football everyone responded on Monday so
well to the to the critiques from our
coaches
um there was a lot of just yes sir I got
you I'll do it right all right now
Denver Coach Nathaniel Hackett came over
from Green Bay where he spent time as
the Packers offensive coordinator so he
is very familiar with Devante Adams
I mean he's a guy I've been with for the
past three years uh he's an amazing
human being somebody that's very dear to
my heart
um but at the same time we got to stop
him and uh I know that he's a dynamic
receiver on how he can get the ball both
both vertically intermediate all over
the place and he's a very smart football
player but we're gonna have to do our
best to contain him as much as we can
and the defense has done a fine job up
to this point the past three games and
it's going to be a great great challenge
for all of them it's not just going to
be one guy all right hey don't